one of the most fascinating developments
of the modern world is the notion of
possible sentient extraterrestrial life
living among the Stars this possibility
presented as scientific speculation is
attractive to those who espouse a
materialistic world view those For Whom
the ancient cosmology in which there are
meaningful patterns in the heavens seems
superstitious and
absurd but now these same people can
nonetheless project their myth logical
thinking into those very heavens you see
the frame of alien life is presented in
scientific language but as soon as we
attempt to imagine these creatures and
their world all the ancient patterns of
human consciousness come flooding
[Music]
in this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
[Music]
world in the ancient world we find a
universal pattern the image of a center
an anchor by which we interpret the
world our home our family our tribe our
Temple but also our own Center of
Consciousness our heart as one moves
further and further from this Center one
finds all that is not aligned with our
identity the neighbor that which we can
still recognize first but soon we find
the
stranger the Foreigner and ultimately
the Barbarian and even animality itself
the Beast and the Fantastical monster as
soon as we move away from that which we
know we fall into a space where things
don't quite have identities yet are not
accounted for within ourselves and these
possibilities will appear to us both in
their positive or negative form either
as a dangerous destructive chaos or else
as the promise of something
more so the ancient Greeks for example
had in Deli the umos the naval of the
world just like the Romans had the
umbilicus from which all the distances
in the empire were calculated the
Israelites had the temple in Jerusalem
now the further one moved away from this
Center the more what was encountered
appeared strange ultimately on the edge
of the world were found Mythic races of
monsters giants inversions like the
Amazons hybrids like dog-headed shape
shifters of all kinds you know and
ultimately Fantastical beasts and sea
monsters but in the same unknown region
was also found stories of great sages
the naked philosophers of the East
Untold Bounty and treasure from far away
lands and even the Garden of Eden these
patterns are not arbitrary they're the
very shape of how we experience reality
every day can be seen as a moving out of
the home into an unknown future when
where where one can find both danger and
opportunity and The Duality of what is
foreign still inhabits The Human
Experience and if the monsters and
treasures were once pushed out to the
outer edges of the earth now these same
tropes are projected into the Infinity
of outer space and so instead of
eliminating this mythological structure
we actually have a radicalization of it
where the impossible distances of our
outer space have also wielded an
infinite canvas for idiosyncrasy
monsters demons but also Angels or
Godlike beings who can offer mankind its
Future these tropes are often understood
by by by the creators of these stories
which is why many extraterrestrial
stories want to connect the question of
these far away aliens with issues and
problems of immigration
Mikey the difficulty in the encounter of
cultures the negative encounter can take
the form of the destructive power of a
monster an invasions of the hordes of
chaos the infiltrator and corruptor of
our world an infection with which
contaminates us all of these an image of
the intrusion of death and the collapse
of all we had identify with but the
encounter can also be positive to the
extreme and the alien civilization can
be used as a foil to humanity showing us
up in some way judging us and here the
aliens are either the higher more
technically perfect and enlightened
beings or else an extreme virgin of the
noble savage a pure people Closer To
Nature all of these are versions of the
same reality which is the the problem of
facing and categorizing something yet
unknown as it appears in the periphery
of our experience and our imagination
how encountering the unknown inevitably
brings about the promise or
confrontation of change and difference
growth or dissolution in that manner
stories of extraterrestrials are a
direct continuation of ancient
narratives of encounters with Far Away
people trade with mysterious
civilizations the pillaging and invasion
of Barbarians or else they all Al recast
the travel to the ends of the Earth
which are exemplified by let's say the
legends of Alexander the Great the story
of Marco poloo or even more recent
literary versions such as Gulliver's
Travels this obviously has both
political and psychological significance
we can imagine the traveler as a
centered figure who then encounters a
wealth of beings each of them
representing a specific aspect a strong
characteristic of human existence which
either shines light by emphasizing a
specific that characteristic itself or
else acts as a foil to a particular
human flaw this manner of presenting
extraterrestrials was particularly Vivid
in the Star Trek series where the
important alien races were portrayed
with an emphasized human characteristic
the Vulcans were reason and Logic the
Klingons were passion and aggression the
frangi were greedy and shrewd the Borg
was Conformity And Hive thinking this is
not much different from the early
Enlightenment science fiction works such
as Sano de bak's comical history of the
states of the empires of the Moon
there's also an important relationship
between aliens and technology and we
know this intuitively because the
stories appeared to us with all the
trappings of Science
Fiction but this relationship is not
happen stance rather it is fully in tune
with the you know the very structure of
our
experience I imagine our ancestors
facing the chaos and danger of the
natural world in order to protect
ourselves from that danger and in order
to take advantage of the opportunities
of the outer world we create layers
around us we have clothing which permits
us to live out where there is more cold
we have houses that do the same as well
and all these practices which protect us
and in that manner all Technologies are
a series of layers which permit us to
live further and further out into
greater and greater danger the ship is
the ultimate example of that both a kind
of shell around us but a vehicle which
permits us to float on the watery chaos
where the monsters
lurk space travel is the modern version
of the ancient Mariners tale who boldly
goes where no man has gone
before the problem though with
supplementing our power with technology
and exploring the unknown with science
is that as we add layers and become
Bolder and Bolder we move out further
and further into that unknown so the
danger is also increasing and so
although we are stronger we are also
more
vulnerable see my access to a matchbook
makes be able to start a fire without
having to plan and think about it but
I've also lost the capacity my ancestors
had to start a fire without those
matches the Reliance on cleaning
products protects me from germs but it
also makes my immune system weaker for
the lack of exposure
drank now imagine we move so far into
the technical world into that double
space of opportunity and danger that we
discover something that could destroy us
all on a personal level more
psychological level imagine that in your
own self you travel so far away from
home so far from yourself that you
encounter something you could not
foresee a Madness at the edge of your
being a chaos or evil so great that it
can consume you face me now I will
devour
you the Alien series of movies explores
this conjunction between all these
symbolic element the alien from this
famous series is an image of an
encounter in the far reaches of space of
a chaos we could not foresee a Beast
which defies all categories which is
constantly transforming mutating The
evolutionary version of a shape shifter
the very name of it the xenomorph joins
the notion of the periphery the outside
with the shifting and changing chaos the
first alien movie makes this not only
about the edge of social cohesion but
also the Edge of Reason and
Consciousness itself so the alien is
related to the nightmare which is why
the crew Encounters this monster as an
interruption of their cry enic sleep the
creature while joining many types of the
humanoid monster the aesthetic of demons
and dragon also Taps into the notion of
the alien as a foreign body and parasite
having insect or Vermin likee qualities
in its
appearance but the alien spreads Itself
by an actual parasite which then infects
its host and enters into it in broader
terms the movies are constantly dealing
with tropes of containment and
evacuation of the foreign body we even
see this burning off at the end of the
first movie but while the alien plays
with all the tropes of contamination it
is also the monster on the edge of the
world the dragon or the Leviathan this
Predator that will devour us if we
wander too far away from the campfire in
the movie Prometheus the unleashing of
this foreign threat the very existent of
the alien species is presented to us as
a weapon for the destruction of mankind
sometimes to
create one must first destroy so imagine
if you will the possibility of
weaponized migration this last example
points to how although the alien movie
presents the negative aspect of this
encounter from far away it also shows us
the other side in several of the movies
the technological advantage presented by
the alien is seen as a potential that is
extremely desirable both in the first
and the second movie part of the drama
OCC occurs around hidden attempts in
some camps to wield the power of the
alien in the first movie the Android Ash
has a secret mission to bring the alien
to Earth linking the very technological
being of Ash to the technical potential
presented by the alien there's also
something of a flavor of ancient
medieval demonology and angiology within
these stories of aliens we see this of
course in how new AG people often link
meeting uh with aliens to spiritual
experiences encounters with angels and
and many Christians apologists have also
linked aliens to demon
possession because demons are creatures
out of the outer Darkness you could say
both oppressing us devouring us but also
infecting us and using our bodies to
their bidding we can see how they
function in a similar manner as aliens
and like in Star Trek demons are usually
linked with certain excess of human
characteristics and so just like the
fangi we have a demon of avarice just
like the Klingon we have Demons of
passion and anger don't number US my we
are Klingons we should therefore not be
surprised to see that stories of alien
objections often discovered when people
are brought out of Consciousness into
hypnotic States would bear similar
stories similar images to stories of
witches of demon possession and the like
all of these patterns surrounding aliens
dive deep into the structure of our
Human Experience they're very useful in
understanding how we perceive difference
how we perceive novelty and especially
how we interact with what is foreign and
on the edge of our civilizations our C
our culture our religious beliefs and
even our own personal being and
rationality you can often tell quite a
bit from a personal person's politics
and their basic view of the world by
discovering which type of
extraterrestrial movie they find most
appealing is one attracted mostly to ET
or Close Encounters of the Third Kind or
is it rather War of the Worlds and
Independence Day or maybe like me you
can see both sides of the question of
what is strange and foreign you can come
to perceive both possible extremes as
well and hopefully through this
discussion I have brought you a bit
further on that path